my name is emir and my stanford secret  is  take the acting class you will develop  your communication skills  engage with the audience in a completely  different way  and you will feel pretty in control on  stage and it's really fun  my name is tiffany and here's my  stanford secret take classes  like running a sales org and dilemmas  and decisions taught by famous venture  capitalists like peter levine from  andreessen horowitz  taking classes with famous venture  capitalists is amazing because you take  all of their experience and knowledge  from looking at hundreds and thousands  of companies  distilled into tight sound bites